hey everyone as many of you know 10 days
ago on Monday September 26th one of the
world's most accomplished ski
Mountaineers and Adventure athletes
Hillary Nelson tragically passed away
while descending mount manusloo in Nepal
after summiting the 26
781 foot mountain with her partner Jim
Morrison she was 49.
tragic loss for her family of course for
Jim for her two kids she leaves behind
for the adventure Community whose
massive outpouring of support has been
the one heartwarming Silver Lining
amidst such a really stricken event also
for the town of Telluride that she
called home and for the countless women
athletes for whom she was an
extraordinary inspiration a mentor and a
role model
for those new to Hillary she really was
one of the greatest to ever do it an
absolute Giant and she did it at the
highest level for decades summiting
exploring skiing some of the most exotic
and treacherous mountain ranges on Earth
including being the first woman to climb
both Everest and its 8 000 meter
neighbor lotsy in a 24-hour period and
also being the first person to ski down
all five of the Mongolian Altis holy
Peaks
unlike many of my friends and past
podcast guests people like Conrad anchor
Jimmy chin Lindsey Dyer Alex Honnold and
and others I didn't know Hillary well
but I did know her back in 2018 I spent
the better part of a day with her she
came to my house
we did a podcast she met my family we
hung out and I gave her a ride to the
other side of town you know essentially
enough time to leave me like so many
fairly restricken by her loss and and
wanting to honor her life and her Legacy
and the best way that I know how to do
that is to re-release that 2018
conversation in my original introduction
to that episode I wrote quote
this is an incredible conversation about
fear risk resilience adventure and
potential it's about balancing the pull
of Adventure against Hillary's
responsibility as a single mom to two
boys she was single at the time and it's
about the Allure of the outdoors but
mostly this is an exchange about the
virtues of placing yourself outside your
comfort zone and what that can teach us
about potential
preciousness of life and what it means
to be truly alive
about
of course this now leaves us asking what
is acceptable risk well Hillary had her
own calculation for this and she
understood and appreciated the risk that
she incurred better than any of us can
possibly imagine
and in the end I think it's fair to say
that she truly was alive truly alive and
she pursued her life with this laudable
Vigor to the absolute fullest and well
of course we lost her way too soon her
Legacy her influence those things
Prevail and I think much can still be
learned from someone who so fully
embraced all of it because
none of us are promised at tomorrow
so this is for you Hillary
rest in power
all right let's do it okay
I don't know what do you want to talk
about I don't know I got lots of stuff I
want to talk about we can talk about
whatever you want to talk about
um I'm just delighted to be in your
presence super nice to meet you thanks
thanks for having me yeah welcome to Los
Angeles yeah um I guess the first time
yeah I know it's crazy we actually are
having like a really warm day finally it
was it was pretty cold here I mean for
La a couple days ago oh really Frost in
the mornings oh yeah yeah it's funny it
was exciting I notoriously don't
necessarily look at the weather yeah for
places I'm going I showed up with like a
down jacket and like all kinds of warm
winter clothes from Tahoe well maybe
last week that would have been
appropriate Yeah Yeah well yeah I would
imagine you're pretty prepared wherever
you go yeah exactly usually for snow
maybe not for like traffic though it's
funny I came in here earlier we were
setting up and that air conditioning was
on I was like oh it's so cold in here
it's going to be really cold and I was
like wait a minute
it'll be okay I'll be more comfortable
yeah
um well first of all congratulations on
being named one of the 2018 National
Geographic what is it adventurers of the
year yeah thank you exciting thanks it's
cool what does that mean yeah it means a
lot to me yeah I worked really hard last
year I had kind of a crazy last couple
of years
um
just in my life in general and so to
really go for it last year was a big
deal for me and then to be recognized by
National Geographic for it was pretty
pretty awesome it's cool it's cool and
it was well first of all just for the
listeners out there I was super excited
to also see Alex Honnold as one of the
yeah and what he did last year was
absolutely incredible he was he was just
in here a couple weeks ago okay he's
pretty awesome and also maybe even more
special was seeing Myrna Valerio Reagan
I don't know much about her but I have
done a little reading up on her
she sounds pretty incredible she's
awesome I've had her on the podcast okay
you're like National Geographic there's
two more right there's five total so I'm
gonna have to track down the other two
yeah no I think there's like eight of us
for this year yeah there's Killian
jornay oh yeah
um and then this female this Surfer I'm
not I don't know her very well and a
couple scientists yes cool so so that
that was really based on this Expedition
that you did this past year I mean
you've yes you've done like a bazillion
I can't I don't know I'm like I don't
even know I can't pronounce any of these
names anyway but but it you know walk me
through what you did this past year that
got you on that inductee list well
I have been obsessed with this mountain
in India ever since my very first
expedition in the skin totally date me
it was like way back in 1999. a
different Century yeah
um and so in 2017 I've made one attempt
on the peak before in 2013 to know Avail
like we didn't really get very far on
the Mountain at all and in 2017 between
2013 and 2017 just a lot kind of went on
in my life in general and
I'd actually had kind of a lot of not
successful Expeditions that I'd been a
part of in fact some were like just
total disasters and I
really wanted to go back to pupsura it's
called the peak of evil would you really
get which is a better name so epic right
yeah pretty epic if you're gonna need
you know something yeah like that yeah
it really is a good thing I understand
the call yeah so there was just it was
just calling me to go back and it was
kind of like I saw it as this
circle of life kind of of my life and
sort of a place where I started in a
place I wanted to go back to and
ultimately you know end with some
success so what is it that that
spoke to you or speaks to you about the
peak of evil like why do you why like
I'm interested in how you make the
choices that you make and like it seems
like you're very deliberate you take
your time but once you're in you're all
in so what you know how do you make that
decision like why was that one so
important even though I know you've been
there before in 2013 but well to just to
give you a little background of how I
like to climb and where I like to go in
in nearly a 20-year career of
expeditions I've never been back to the
same place twice I like to I've been
back to Regions but never the same
Mountain I really like the adventure and
the mystery and the unknown and all that
logistical planning that goes into it
but for some reason popsura just kept
pulling me back in and I think in large
part when a friend of mine first showed
it to me all those years ago
it just looks so unattainable and so
beyond anything I had the skill set for
because
it was just this massive incredibly
remote Peak with to me and and I'm a
skier first in a climber second it just
had this I mean I think about the
aesthetic of the peak and the ski line
on it and it just gives me the chills
and it's like this photo just seared in
my brain of this mountain
and I think that I mean I was in my
early 20s when I first saw this mountain
and
was very new to the combination of
Alpine climbing and combining it with
skiing and big ski descents and
it just it just seemed like this
absolutely perfect
Mountain that I would never be able to
climb
then Flash Forward 17 18 years and
I just changed my skill set and I worked
really hard at learning things and
putting myself into different
um difficult situations in the mountains
and
just getting that skill set in general
so what is it that you had to master to
to do that one like what was specific
about that like I know it wasn't it yeah
yeah we're gonna talk about suffering
yeah but
but I read maybe maybe I'm mixing up
Expeditions but doesn't this have like a
60 degree descent like it's super yes
super steep it was really steep I was
just talking about it the other day
uh
at this sort of speaking thing in
um Estes Park in Colorado and this guy
who was a climber in the back was like
well I mean you had your ice axes so you
know if you lost an edge couldn't you
have self-arrested and
I don't even know what that means
self-arresting basically means if you
fall on something steep you have this
really pointy sharp metal thing that you
use to like slam into the side of the
mountain so you don't slide all the way
down but the the conditions were such
that they're if you lost an edge it was
there was no way you could possibly stop
yourself and it was that Steep and it
was you know kind of this hard glacial
ice with just a tiny bit you know a
couple centimeters of snow on top of it
so it was really
um
really intense I mean I can't say we
made a lot of ski turns we descended on
our skis wow how long did it take you to
descend
four hours to do about 3 000 feet which
if you compare that to skiing like a
powdery spine in Alaska it might take 30
seconds you know wow so a big difference
in timing and just uh focus and
a big challenge with that face is it's
there's not it's at the top of it is
over 21 000 feet
and there's not really a way to
acclimatize
once you're on the face you start you
know at 17
000 and 17 800 and you have to go all
the way to the top and you can't really
acclimatize in there so I mean you're an
endurance athlete yourself so I know but
it's like it's like you have to train
for this endurance side of things that
is really unique because it's very slow
paced when you're at that high of
altitude but then also your decision
making is compromised you're about the
oxygen yeah yeah but you trained you so
you did this with this guy his name's
Jim Morrison
my significant other yeah yeah and and
you guys trained like on Telluride like
doing crazy right so I think this this
was all part of the National Geographic
recognition was that we started by
training uh because for me it's not
about training to be an athlete it's
training for exposure and
mental state when you're in a tough
position I've been an athlete my whole
life so yeah yeah I'm sorry to step on
you no no that's okay but like I'm
interested in in how you see it breaking
down between
the you know how much of this is mental
versus physical oh I mean
this all kind of goes into suffering it
all comes back to suffering but for me I
like to get into that space where it
becomes way more mental than physical
and
I only do that through kind of intense
long endurance climbing
but obviously you have to have a high
physical level of training and then
combine that with
the mental side of it I mean having kids
really has helped train my mental my
mental Fitness but uh at some point
the physical fitness the physicality of
climbing only gets you so far
and
what really helps me to succeed and
maybe others like like Alex Honnold or
Conrad Inc or uh is
being able to draw
physical strength through mental
toughness right and Beyond being a
mother how I mean how do you develop
that for yourself I mean is that just a
matter of putting you into those
situations where you're tested
yeah it is I I mean it's really easy for
me to put on running shoes and go for a
run and keep that physical fitness level
ride my road bike go go for a mountain
bike but to get that exposure training
you I really have to put myself into
situations where
Telluride is a great place to do this
because of the these crazy coolers that
are in the mountains there I can get
into a really tight coolar that you know
rolls to 45 degrees and then you have to
pull out ropes and
you know you can't fall or you're going
to fall over a cliff you have to really
like be on every turn and that to me is
where the real training kicks in and
plus you're starting to work with all
the gear you need harnesses
ropes
it's like even way more like all right
that's ridiculous let's like Define our
terms here okay yeah I know there's a
lot of mountaineering terms well first
of all like when you first came across
my radar I'm like wait what like she
does what like I thought like you know
climbing or mountaineering you know
Alpine that's its own little subculture
and then you've you you're even you're
in this subculture within a sculpt
subculture yeah Super Key mountaineering
and I'm like what is that even in like
where did this person come from and how
does that work you know like you're not
only ascending these insane Peaks but
you're doing it with skis and then
skiing back down right yeah so that
complicated things because I mean in
some ways I like
the skiing part of it because it it
keeps what you're climbing up to a
certain level because you have to be
able to ski down it so I'm not climbing
up El Cap carrying skis that would be
interesting that would be interesting
you know so it has to be some sort of
I don't know mountain or objective that
while it has pretty intense
Alpine climbing side to it you still
have to be able to ski down it right or
or you know ski descend yeah yeah how
many people are in this little world oh
my gosh it's such a small little niche
yeah I mean Backcountry skiing or side
country skiing which is when you would
go up Mammoth and you would go out back
I don't know if Mammoth has back into
Gates but you'd you know go into the
side country uh back country is where
you're just ski touring there's tons of
that in the Sierra mountains there's
tons of that all over the U.S the Alps
where you put skins on your skis and you
walk up something and you ski back down
ski mountaineering I Define it as
something that's more multi-day
and typically requires travel to some
sort of foreign exotic adventurous place
that's not doesn't have to be but that's
ski mountaineering and ski
mountaineering to me involves crampons
which are the spiky things on your
bottom of your boots and Ice axes and
harnesses and there's a huge climbing
aspect to it yeah it's uh it's so
dynamic because you have to be you have
to be so multi-disciplinary right and
approach and it's different from Alpine
climbing in the sense that a lot of ski
mountaineering even though you're with
Partners you're you're doing all the
climbing by soloing you're not
necessarily roped together and that was
the case on popsura which was
you know a 3 000 foot 50 to 60 degree
basically ice face that you're just
soloing
and
um and why do you think you were able to
master it this time like what happened
in 2013 what change that allowed you to
conquer it
well the beauty of
going back to a second place
or going back to a place a second time
is you have done all the reconnaissance
and so that was new to me and it really
just allowed me to
not have to focus so much on the
logistical planning and really just
focus on the mountain and the peak and
having already seen it and knowing what
it was all about there was a third
member that went with us so we were a
team of three this time and Chris
figginshaw he was with me in 2013.
I made a lot of logistical changes in
that we went later in the year
so we went this time in May instead of
March and we went with just three of us
in 2013 there were like seven of us
which is just too many for a face like
that and we approached differently so
the biggest problem in 2013 was that we
only had eyes for one particular route
and
after coming home and thinking about it
and thinking how dangerous that
particular approach was
I was able to look at the face
differently and realize that there was a
different approach that was much safer
and longer and better skiing actually so
those kind of changes were made between
the two Expeditions and
in my first try we actually did this
huge like 40 to 50 mile ski Traverse at
altitude and tried to climb and this
time we just went straight in and
straight out right interesting yeah
so well congrats on that yeah it's
pretty amazing and and just kind of
looking at at your career I mean what
you've done I don't know 40 50 of these
activities yeah a lot of expeditions I
mean there's so many of them I had to
like make this like cheat sheet but it's
like some of the highlights like first
to climb Everest and Lot C in 24 hours
yeah yeah has has anybody done that
since
well first I mean probably yeah we'll
end with my partner yeah in 24 hours
yeah that's something yeah
so so yeah Kilimanjaro with a broken leg
Yeah
and with my kids oh my gosh and they
were right with your friends which we're
going to talk about
first ski descents of big peaks in
Mongolia India Russia and Greenland yeah
right yeah and and what's interesting is
you're probably best known for
um this epic expedition in 2014 where
you went to Burma yeah and attempted
this
mountain called for Kubo Raze
yeah I was almost there I almost got it
you pretty much had it um I watched the
documentary uh down to nothing which was
oh really cool I mean the cinematography
is so extraordinary I mean that is a
story in and of itself with Renault and
Corey Richards making
massive efforts and sacrifices in making
that film yeah so I mean let's talk
about this for a little bit I I think
just as a as a preparatory comment to
even you know discussing this particular
Expedition I find what I find
interesting about your career is you
know there's a lot of missteps and you
know quote-unquote I hate that word
failure but like but there's no more
yeah yeah and and you just keep going
and and so I'm interested in your
relationship with failure like what does
that mean what does it represent to you
how does it you know motivate you or
play into how you approach each
adventure and think about it in the
aftermath well
ski mountaineering Alpine climbing I
think Expeditions in general don't
typically have over the span of a career
a high percentage of success rates so I
would say I mean I'm probably pretty 50
50 on success and
you know I I like getting to the top of
a mountain as silly as that sounds like
energy that can drive you to do this I'm
you know that's obviously very yeah yeah
I mean and you put so much effort like
Burma for example was two years of
planning before we actually even stepped
foot in the country and
I mean I I went to
Pakistan for an 8 000 meter peak when my
first son was 10 months old and didn't
Summit you know and that was like
heartbreaking to
make this time away and and not be
successful so there's there's a lot of
things that I perceive as failures but
I've also had to sort of redefine what
success means to me along the way and
success in some ways is here sitting
here with you and telling stories about
these Expeditions and things that I've
learned about
the human nature and interpersonal
relationships and
banging your head against a wall
sometimes and overcoming
failure is um
become
sort of I guess my success story and
some weird Twisted way so if you had to
distill down those lessons and I know
you get up in front of people all the
time you're gonna talk tonight you know
what is that message that you're trying
to convey when you tell these stories
I think it's truly truly
a necessity to have
a passion as a compass in life
but to have a passion
on some levels really sucks and it's
hard and
if it's worth it you're gonna fall on
your face several times on your way to
like sort of
reaching
the goal that is the Fulfillment of this
passion and
I've done it epically on many levels but
I
I think happiness is a is not a great
word to use I don't like that word I
think just
in search of happiness or fulfillment or
just uh uh
a deeper understanding of my own self
and how I can inspire people has been
really the culmination of those times
Falling on My Face reaching that passion
so yeah so so in other words like
passion is uh
you know has its has its beauty and it
has its dark side it has a really dark
side too it's a you know it's a close
bed fellow of obsession
are familiar with fine line between the
two and the pursuit of of that passion
or the following of that Obsession in
your case involves
you know suffering and also Elation
right but suffering is unavoidable and
in fact suffering is a key component to
connecting with yourself in that way
like on that path to like you know
really trying to understand what makes
you tick so that you can come back
more fulfilled with something to say
right is that accurate yeah and I mean I
think
I think it come
down to how if you don't have
suffering in your life how do you
experience the opposite how do you
understand what Elation is what
fulfillment is if you don't
experience the opposite and if you
haven't had major failures in your life
and been able to make something of them
turn them into
something you've learned from and how do
you
appreciate the successes that you have
in life
yeah it's all connected it is it is and
I I think well a couple observations you
know most people maybe not most people
but there's a lot of people who
who don't have that true north that
drives them they don't have a passion or
they don't know what it feels like to
have some form of healthy Obsession
right that propels them forward
you know and that combined with a
culture that emphasizes you know
security and safety and luxury and
comfort at the you know at the forsaking
of suffering
um creates a population of people who
are not connected in the way that you're
intimately familiar with right so I
would imagine when you go and you speak
you probably meet a lot of people that
might say something along those lines to
you like I don't know you know how does
that feel to be that way how do I find
my passion right I definitely get a lot
of questions of like what drives you
what what makes you go back to to
continue doing this and
why yeah
um and you know there's been uh plenty
of times in my life when I'm and take
peak of evil for instance when I like
wake up in the middle of the night
obsessing you know this crazy dream that
I'm back on that mountain and I have to
go back and I mean believe me I just
wish it would go away sometimes and I
could just
be content with being comfortable and
having showers and right almost like you
have no free will like yeah and you're
fulfilling some past life Destiny
The Reincarnation of a Himalayan Sherpa
or something yeah something yeah it's
wild
um it's cool I mean look you know the
subject of I mean suffering is something
I you know appreciate yeah understand
the value of and I've had plenty of
guests and lots of your North Face
teammates right you know sat across from
me and I you know I'm remembering Dean
karnaz's speaking eloquently about you
know the the importance of suffering in
his own life as a really as a tool as a
vehicle to you know to that
um deepening that quickening of
connection with self that allows you to
really understand what makes you tick
and be a fully integrated person right
right and so whether it's running or
climbing or whatever your
your driving nor star is yeah maybe it's
music maybe it's your job or your family
whatever it is
um you have to work hard for it
something you just have to work hard for
and and and stop looking for the
shortcut but actually embrace that
difficult journey ahead right yeah yeah
I just popped into my mind that movie
Whiplash do you see that movie about the
drummer yes yeah so yeah analogous
example it's just a different context
right it's kind of that same message
yeah suffering and enduring
discomfort and I mean and I've said this
a a bunch of times like one of my
biggest fears in life is getting is just
being too comfortable and you know
having every day be the same and I think
I go to
sometimes unhealthy extremes to
keep that from coming to pass you know
so let me throw a word at you and and if
you could respond
what what comes to mind when I say
balance
hmm
I mean the first thing that comes to
mind
I get asked a lot like how do you
balance it all and I I don't
um to me balance is a moving Target I
think it's this sort of
ever
morphing
thing that I strive for
um
how do I balance
being a mom doing these Expeditions I I
find myself
compartmentalizing a lot and
I don't I just I don't have a lot of
balance in my life well I think I think
you know I think we're we've become
confused about this subject matter of
like how do you how do you live a
balanced life or how do you find balance
it's more for me like
reconciling like my love for the
suffering and all these other things
that other people think is is out of
balance like that's my equilibrium point
like the pendulum is swinging you know
it always has to come back to the center
of looking at it actually yeah you know
it's like that you're it's just if you
look at your the way I describe it for
myself and and maybe you'll relate to
this is like if you look at your life
over a one year or two year three year
period like
it probably looks balanced the time with
your kid whatever right it's not going
to look like somebody else's life but
yeah it's not balanced to like okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna you know my kids are
gonna stay at home I'm gonna go to
Pakistan yeah like yeah yeah that's
that's not balancing the traditional
sense but that's something that you are
compelled to do in order for you to find
your own Equanimity right right right so
it's yeah I when I look at my life over
a longer stretch of time I see the
balance
in that length of time when I look at
yeah in the macro when I look at it in
this micro picture to me it's you know
there's a lot of highs and lows and
there's there's you know just
swinging back and forth and craziness
and I think I think climbing an
expedition life in general lends itself
to Crazy emotional swings where you're
and and as an athlete yourself I'm sure
you can relate to this you you have
these goals and you focus
so hard within the moment to attain
these goals and then when you get there
it's kind of like
this this crazy letdown on some level
and so emotionally you're you're kind of
this this up and down yo-yo effect but
yeah over time in the macro picture
it's it smoothes out it normalizes it
balances itself I like how uh I I
cracked up when I saw this that like
you're trying to sort of in an effort to
kind of maybe normalize a little bit
you're like I need to be home a little
bit more so rather than go out on three
or four Expeditions a year I'm gonna do
one and I'm gonna do an Iron Man that'll
give me more time with my kids like most
people's like an Iron Man you're never
gonna be home you know it's like for you
that's like really like shrinking it
down to a manageable task yeah that was
my 2000 that was my 2016. I didn't go on
a single Expedition but I how the Iron
Man get off I did an Iron Man which one
did you do
it was in North Carolina
and uh it was a new one and I don't know
if they did it again but they cut the
bike ride in half because they'd just
gotten that big hurricane and
um so I got a little chip so now I guess
now I'm like I have to do another one
all right let's talk about the uh
hakubois
so in this movie I mean look there's so
many like interesting aspects to this
Expedition but
um
but you know I think one of the things
that made it super unique is well you I
want you to describe it but you have
this like 30-day Trek you know through
you know the jungle just to get to like
the base camp yeah and that was like you
know before you even start actually
ascending this incredible Mountain yeah
you guys are just have already met and
faced and had to overcome like a
bazillion unforeseen obstacles right
it's crazy right what can you just like
helicopter into base camp and whatever
harder than it already was the the
premise behind that expedition like the
majority of us had just come off of the
Mount Everest climb a few years before
and we were really like trying to do
something very anti-everest in the sense
of just a complete unknown Adventure
and
that involved traveling Overland so
they're really first of all there isn't
really an option to fly in with a
helicopter it's just doesn't happen
there and it's super sketchy and I
wouldn't want to be in a helicopter that
would fly that far north in that
particular country in that region right
so we're in Burma so we're in Burma it's
the same thing right Myanmar yes so
right before we went in 2014 Obama
officially as the United States
recognized the new name and started
calling it Myanmar so we you know in the
film I think we refer to it as Myanmar
but yeah Burma Myanmar and I go back and
forth in how I use it because it's still
the Burmese people that live in Myanmar
but um
we ended up I mean Myanmar is a unique
place to begin with had been closed off
for decades to westerners most
definitely in that very Northern Region
and something a lot of people don't know
I didn't really even realize this is
that it's the the Himalayas that drop
down into the northern part of Burma
and that's where we were headed so it's
the very Eastern tale of the Himalayas
that end in Burma and so the idea was
you're gonna chart uh this mountain it's
never been ascended and no one really
knows exactly how high it is right so
you're going to get a GPS reading on it
and make it official right so it had
been climbed once in 1996 by this
Japanese man who had subsequently been
killed on Everest a few years later and
he was a famous you know Japanese
climber I'm totally spacing his name
right now of course because I whatever
but um he described it as the most
difficult Mountain he'd ever been on or
near and he he made it to the top on his
third climb his third attempt
and didn't have any kind of GPS he did
the jungle he did the jungle thing he
did the Jungle jungle track multiple
times wow and but that was 20 years yeah
prior to our trip so and no one had
really been in there since then so it
was uh just an adventure and we went
Overland from being gone which is over a
thousand miles south of the mountain and
walked
um 150 miles Through the Jungle over two
weeks
it was like day 30 when it was day 30
when we got to base camp from the day we
left the United States to base camp was
30 days and what was cool in the movie
is there's little dials like odometers
yeah your food you know like how much
food you have and you could see it like
oh man it's yeah it's gonna be a problem
yeah and that was the biggest problem
was running out of food and they were
just you know unforeseen things like
getting bribed out of our rice reserves
by the sort of military outposts and
some of these remote Villages and like
your gas didn't work right or something
like that yeah and we you know my my
history in planning Expeditions is doing
it in
Nepal in India and even Pakistan where
they have a huge history of climbers
coming to their mountains and that
history just doesn't exist that
infrastructure for climbers is
non-existent in Burma and
so finding Porters
to carry help carry our loads back to
this incredibly technical Peak
and uh having enough food to get us back
there like it you know we needed 80
Porters yeah we had about 25 or 30 so we
had to cut our gear by two-thirds
um it just you know it was just it was
epic yeah well I mean and I think I've
heard you say this before like like
that's adventure adventure is is
Adventure begins when things start going
wrong right right yeah it all goes
smooth and how much of an adventure was
it really right I mean and the irony is
that you know yeah we spent two years
planning this trip and then you get
there and ever everything you plan just
kind of goes out the window and right
but you know you have to take time to
get permits and just just legal
logistical things and then once you're
actually there and
the immigration officers are stopping
you in the airport and telling you that
your all these permits you work so hard
to get are no good and you can't get on
the plane and you can't get I mean it
was just one thing after another but
yeah see to throw down some some dollars
here and there yeah there's a little bit
of a
little bit of losing things out along
the way
and there's no
like trying to figure this out on Google
Maps right there's no like route Maps or
anything there's no route Maps there's
no information on the peak whatsoever
and Google only can take you so far and
you know of course like a lot of 90 of
the technical part of the climb on
Google Maps when you look at the the
imagery is all like blurred out so you
can't really tell what you're up against
and uh yeah I mean it was
on one hand it was totally awesome yeah
I mean it was exactly what we were
looking for we just forgot to remind
ourselves of that when we were in it
and this was a National Geographic like
sponsored Expedition and yeah you were
the team leader there were five of you
there was one other woman yep
um and there's been you know there's
sort of this widely you know documented
publicized Rift that took place when it
came to who was going to make the final
push up to the summit right um and that
was you know in the movie it kind of
just glossed over that aspect right it
didn't make a big deal of that but it's
certainly been a lot written about that
and you were you know kind of outspoken
about not being one of those people and
and I think it it's uh if you're willing
to talk about it you know in light of
kind of you know we're having a cultural
moment right now yeah female empowerment
the male female yeah you know this is
your this is your time Hillary yes this
is an amazing moment right now and as
somebody who is you know a phenomenal
female role model you know an embodiment
of female empowerment
um can you walk me through like what
happened and and kind of how you I mean
that was this was a couple years ago now
right how you know your your perspective
on it now in all in light of kind of
what's happening at the moment right
so it
this has always been a hard thing for
the last few years for me to really talk
about it in a clear succinct way there
like so many things in life there were
so many
complicating factors and contributing
personalities contributing histories
that made this situation so unique and
so difficult I have been climbing and
skiing Mountains for like I said a
really long time and I've never
experienced this type of Team Dynamic
before and I think
you know
whether or not I should have been on the
three out of the five of us to go to the
summit I should have been included in
the conversation and that's where things
really went South but if I can paint you
a picture of where we were you know we
left base camp with really like eight
days of food to go off into more
absolutely unknown terrain we made it up
to this High Ridge at about 18 000 feet
and it's incredibly exposed so maybe
it's only eight feet wide at most and 50
feet long and it just drops off into
sheer Cliffs all all around it so the
wind was blowing you know gusting 50 60
miles an hour and we're trying to have
these conversations and figure out how
we're going to go forward and the stress
and the stress we were already you know
fairly starving uh we already felt like
we just skirted death several times just
even getting to base camp and
there were you know really I conceived
of this trip with a co-leader on the
Expedition Mark Jenkins and he was a
writer for National Geographic and has
done tons of expeditions himself and is
a writer
which I said and
um what happened was basically the
disintegration of our relationship
as climbing partners
on this Expedition and
I think
my naivete if you will was that I
thought the trip was about the two of us
climbing and to me sometimes that's more
important than really reaching the
summit it's really just maintaining that
partnership and that interpersonal
relationship and Mark had this whole
back history going on of where he'd been
there to try this mountain before with
his two best friends who in the
intervening years had both been killed
in climbing accidents and I think his
vision was that he was going to climb
with renan and Corey and sort of reenact
this
moment that he wanted to relive
to honor his best friends and I knew
nothing about that and so he just sort
of manipulated the situation to where he
was climbing with Corey and renan and
just completely cut Emily and I out of
the equation Emily admittedly was Emily
Harrington who's an incredible climber
uh I mean she kind of said like I'm done
I'm good she was done she was pushed to
her Point uh but in no small part
because of uh the the pressures from the
rest of the team put on her but it was
this was a new train for her so her
stepping out of it was totally
understandable and and the right thing
and I think it was just the way it came
across at high camp where
uh I found myself in this position of
like totally shocked and like what are
you guys talking about like what do you
mean I'm not part of this climb to the
summit like I know how to climb and my
climbing came into question and
it was just really
an awful uncomfortable
uh situation and
um sent me into quite a tail spin for
months after the expedition of it was
this a female thing because as a female
in a mostly male climbing world I am
constantly feeling like I have to prove
myself and you know at some point when
I've been doing this long enough it's
like all right I am who I am I am what I
am your National Geographic adventure of
the year right right do you have
anything to prove to anybody but I can
imagine you know how challenge I mean I
can barely imagine like how challenging
that must have been so these three guys
go off they make the push they
ultimately have to retreat right
um and then you've got like the movie
just kind of you know suddenly you know
Flash Forward and you guys are home
basically but like right
to do that hike again yeah we had to
hike all that way out again fractured
you know sir there's no Unity amongst
the group anymore did you have to repair
that to make it home yeah we did we did
repair it
um to some extent for sure with Corey
and renan and Corey Richards who's in
one of the most incredible photographers
I've ever
been able to work with and he did a
National Geographic photographer and he
just has incredible raw talent but he's
also a very
temperamental person he is incredibly
confrontational and we've done stuff
together and we have these this
interaction where we can like or growl
at each other and fight and then we get
over it and we talk about it and we work
through it and we move on and that is
exactly what happened with Burma and
renan is quite different in that he's
very stoic he's he's quiet he he doesn't
go
you know deep into conversation about
these things but
um
uh you know that's just his way of
dealing with a situation but we you know
talked quite a bit as well on the way
out and really it was just Mark who
really dug his heels in about
um both Emily and I and not
considering our skills to be up to par
uh there was I don't know if you read
some of Mark's blogs
yeah I was um but I heard there was
fairly Village that were made and then
you you were placed in a position of
having to respond to that like yeah yeah
are you guys like are you good now or is
that just no not really with
um and I'm okay with that too no no
we're not and I are great and Corey and
I are great and same with Emily but Mark
just uh he said he's you know he beats
to his own drum to begin with and
I am old enough in my
wise enough if I could use that word to
just not need to repair certain
relationships and to be okay with that
Etc well let's let's uh let's take it
back a little bit okay um
well I mean I wanted to talk about that
and I appreciate your being open about
that
um
in order to really kind of understand
your career and What Makes You tick I
think we really have to understand your
background your childhood a little bit
yeah
um you know you grew up in a very
interesting you know adventuresome type
of family situation you have to go on
these crazy boat trips and right but it
wasn't like you were that little kid
skier from day one like you were playing
all kinds of sports right grew up in
Seattle
I grew up in Seattle and I kind of had
this same sort of life that I see myself
in now only mine's a little more extreme
but we were the very like
normal
mom stayed at home dad went to work I
played traditional Sports so did my
brother and sister we lived in the
suburbs and in the Summers we would get
on this old wooden Chris Craft boat and
then go off and have these crazy
Adventures up in the Inside passage in
Canada and you know be on the boat for
weeks on end you know sometimes you know
the whole summer you name it and this is
before cell phones and things like that
so yeah I mean that the freedom and the
the kind of
um
I don't know openness yeah I would
imagine kind of informed your path on
some level right I mean later the way I
kind of look at is I had this these
really too strong influences and one is
that structure of
team sports and for me it was basketball
which was the main one and and then I
had this freedom and this Wild Side
whereas like a five-year-old I'm running
my own boat and you know and like black
Waters of Canada and on these beaches
and there's bears and fishing and all of
that and
kind of pairing those two sides to me is
very
um
sort of mirrors where I'm at now where I
have this home life and kids and and
then I go off on these big Expeditions
right right kind of how how a lot of
times I feel like I'm two different
people yeah
it sounds like Dad was kind of intense
my dad my head is pretty intense yes he
was like the guy at the soccer games or
the basketball games like yeah I'm
getting heated yeah he's that guy yeah
I can't I mean there are countless games
that basketball games that you just got
straight up thrown out of the gym
and uh you know he he was my coach so
basically I played basketball with the
same group of women from the time I was
seven years old to 18 years old so and
he wanted you to be like a college
basketball player he wanted me to be a
college basketball player and he was
very much I mean he still watches the
videotapes of my basketball games and
still is like I can't believe you missed
that shot are you serious yes yes yeah
so wow so that's I mean look that's
heavy right heavy yeah I mean when
you're in it when you're a kid you don't
know any different but like right you
don't know any difference in intense
situations so and he was really intense
with my brother and my sister and where
are you in the pecking order of your
siblings like I am the youngest the
youngest yes oh wow so he maintained
that and did he was he throwing down on
the on your brothers and sisters too or
yeah much more so than me I think I got
the
not too much though well and I also
learned how to like kind of duck and
dive I was pretty good at it so but
with that comes generally you know the
that sort of I mean you want that
approval right like you're you right
yeah you know if he's like hey you
should have done this done that like
yeah yeah and it's funny I mean I I of
course then ultimately went down a path
that he doesn't a an athletic path that
he doesn't understand or relate to and
and to his credit he supported me the
whole way and has done you know a lot of
effort trying to understand it a little
bit better and uh
you know would pull along the way of
being like when are you gonna get a real
job when are you gonna stop doing this
and I think in large part because what I
do scares my parents yeah you know
because they don't understand it yeah
yeah they're not unique in that
um but the but it doesn't even kick in
until you're at Colorado College right
like right so I mean were you gonna play
basketball Colorado College or you just
decided you weren't going to be a
basketball player well I had decided I
wasn't going to be a basketball player
but Dad did had a different plan so he
he went out to school and not Colorado
College doesn't have like a a major
basketball team you know that's not
their focus it's not that kind of place
so he uh came out with me like that
orientation week and you know and I'd
already told them I wasn't going to play
basketball and I very much remember him
being like Oh you know I just wanna
let's go let's just go look at the gym
and I have a team though they have a
team and he'd actually secretly set up
this meeting with the coach telling her
that I wanted to play and oh my gosh it
resulted in probably one of the biggest
fights I've ever had with my dad but um
it also ping-ponged me like off the
sidelines and away from the yeah the
structure and the other way yeah I was
like I think I'm just going on like why
is he wired like that uh you know he
I think it was
a part of his kids life that he could
tangibly have an effect on and be
present for and he didn't have that in
his own life growing up and so he really
went deep with it and
I
you know I learned
a lot from him and some of it is the
opposite of probably how he meant for me
to absorb what he was but the drive the
focus the drive the ability to like
really like prepare like all of that
like diligence I would imagine you know
in some respect is driven by you know
kind of growing up underneath his
umbrella yeah yeah I would say yeah all
right so you're a Colorado College you
have the blowout basketball happening
you figure out like oh skiing's pretty
good here and there's lots of cool
mountains and yeah you just get into it
that's where it kind of begins I mean I
luckily like first week of going to
Colorado College I kind of fell in with
this group of friends that were rock
climbers and back country skiers and
just way more into that Adventure side
of things that I didn't know anything
about I mean I grew up in Seattle
Washington where most Mountaineers like
go to be Mountaineers and I left Seattle
to learn how to be a mountaineer so
it was really just about who I started
connecting with and and that school in
particular really encourages sort of
these alternative
Sports and Adventures and we'll have
that cool thing where you you just do
one class for like I don't know a month
and then you get all this you get like a
week off or something like that and so
we'd have these block breaks where we'd
go to Red Rocks in Nevada and do these
huge climbs or you know you're
surrounded by Colorado fourteeners and I
started like climbing up mountains to
ski down them and
had never
used my athleticism in that way and I
would never say that I am like this
incredible downhill skier I'm really
good at it but I'm not
Ingrid Backstrom or I'm not like a
Lindsey Vonn by any stretch of the
imagination but you put those together
and it's like yeah like this magical
thing right so so when you first tap
into this is there like a knowingness
like oh this is my this is going to be
my thing or was it just a gradual like
yeah like this I want to do a little bit
more and it just kind of evolved or yeah
it was pretty gradual for me it was
gradual I uh just the more because I
mean you have to understand I knew
absolutely nothing about it I didn't
even know rock climbing existed until I
was 19 and went to the Garden of the
Gods the first time and was like whoa
ropes and harnesses and what is all this
and I
uh
I mean I just I loved it right
right so you decide to go to chamanee
yeah that was right I was just gonna go
for a few months yeah and then you were
there for like five or six years I was
there for a really long time but that's
like kind of the mecca right this is
where all these things yeah it was the
Mecca and I went there really because of
the downhill skiing that I'd seen in
like all the ski movies of of that era
the blizzard of Oz and so on and so
forth and uh ended up realizing what a
huge component climbing is to the skiing
that takes place in chamonix and that
was when I started getting into ice axes
and
crampons and
all that technical side that goes with
right ice and snow and Glaciers and all
of that and was there a thing at that
time called like ski mountaineering or
were you I mean was there there's a
community there right but was there a
community in that specific discipline or
does that just go with like hey if
you're gonna ski you gotta like hike
with the stuff I think it was more of
the latter it was like Hey if you're
gonna ski you have to take because there
the lift access is so integrated with
climbing mountains and skiing so it's
all it's it was before we had
sort of access off of our own ski areas
in the United States everything was
really boundaried in the U.S at that
point so and it's not so much anymore
but in Germany you could get off a lift
and go anywhere you wanted yeah I mean I
remember the statistic when I first
moved there that on average one person a
day died in Neshaminy Valley one a day
and it was just from falling in crevices
this is before wingsuits and all that so
I'm sure the number and and yeah base
jumping and just lining yeah whatever
yeah everything so
um so it was also my introduction to
the pitfalls of this thing that I love
so much and
you know starting to see people closer
and closer to me you know dying in the
mountains and what that meant and
processing that and that eventually was
the reason I left shamini was because I
was becoming very
flippant and unemotional towards death
and
I
didn't think that was okay it was really
scary
was there was there a moment like how
many how many people that you knew
passed away during that period of time
oh a lot yeah yeah a lot I mean and
you're 23 or something yeah I was 23
yeah wow 24 yeah I think I left there by
the time I was 28. it was a lot you just
you just start to normalize it like yeah
and you start to really normalize it and
uh
yeah it's it's just not okay does it
make me feel like less precious about
your own life though because you see it
so much and does I mean how did that
impact how you assessed risk at that
time
I don't think I was good at assessing
risk at that time I think I just didn't
know enough I mean I really
and I've said this before it's a miracle
I survived that first winter in chamonix
because I just was
blindly following and woohoo and let's
go this way and uh so it was a
Wicked steep learning curve at first and
I mean I like I was like flying tandem
off the North Face of the aguita medi in
my first couple of weeks being there and
just I don't know what that is but
that's it was scary yeah it's yes but
you're not knowing what you're doing and
I think it was 96 when you won like the
extreme skiing right championship right
you know and the playing field was like
me and two other women right so it was
really new
um and you couldn't just done that right
like I would have thought like whoa oh
well this is obviously my thing right
but at the same time I was also doing
these uh touring combo ski competitions
where you're you're almost like they're
called Rando races now but you're kind
of ski touring through the Peaks and
then you rip the skins off and you ski
something and I was doing really well in
those
and I just found sort of more
satisfaction I'm not somebody who really
likes to jump off cliffs and stuff and
that was more the extreme comps and it's
it's a distinction between competition
and pure adventure for the sake of
Adventure yeah right yeah all right so
then then everything kind of changes
when North Face enters the equation
right which is in the sort of tail end
right in the middle of that yeah like
well no kind of the tail end yeah it was
in 99 so I'd been there three years it
was a little yeah towards the tail end
and they're like hey we want to pay you
and you can go do all this yeah and
you're like wait I can have this as a
career and get paid to do what I'm going
to be doing anyway like that's crazy
like did that did it strike you before
that like oh I could have a career doing
this I mean no not really I mean I
thought I could I at the time in Germany
I was doing great at making enough money
to perpetuate staying there so I was you
know winning money from competitions I
was doing some really cheesy ski
modeling and like you know Bogue one
pieces yeah
they're pretty funny yeah uh and then uh
and then I kind of got on the map with
North Face through a friend who was an
athlete with them at the time
and he sort of bridged that connection
which is how a lot of paths get taken I
think in life is just connections and
timing
and three weeks later I was on an
expedition in India right which was
where I saw Pap sura the peak of evil to
bring it all full circle and
I mean that that threw in like high
altitude and winter camping and heavy
packs and I just loved it I don't know
it was
I think a big part too was like this
wide-eyed girl who'd hardly traveled in
her whole life and going to India and
this culture and the craziness and
Madness of India was just really
eye-opening for me and now having
visited all these amazing places over
the years like what do you
take away from being immersed in these
various cultures like how does that
impact you in terms of how you perceive
life here in America like is it does it
change or shift your value set at all
most definitely I
I talk about this a lot with my kids
even trying to explain like Mom's
re-entry into the United States of
America and what that means and
I have a hard time with it I
think that
some of the systems we have in place in
this country are
detrimental to the soul
of us as human beings
um we create too much culture no we're
not the happiest culture and I think
that's the thing that stuck with me the
most from my very first trip to India
was going through seeing real poverty
for the first time and
shacks and shanties and kids with no
shoes and dirty clothes and
um you know families living in a hundred
square foot
hovel basically and what really struck
me was the smiles on these kids faces
and the closeness of the family unit
and the brightness in their eyes
to me looked like happiness in a form
I'd never seen it before
and in a place I couldn't even conceive
of
and
how do you
reconcile
that with what we as Americans
consider happiness of like the new car
and the big house and the white picket
fence and possessions the latest phone
right so how do you reconcile that as a
mother with two boys that are what like
ten and eight or something like that
yeah ten and eight uh you know it's I
I like to
have I've taken my kids to Nepal I've
taken them to to different places and
I hope to continue doing that and just
you know we live in a very fairly utopic
Town Telluride Colorado and it's an
amazing place an incredible Community
for kids to grow up in but they need to
see and experience cultures outside of
that particular culture and outside of
the United States because I I don't
think our way is the end-all answer to a
fulfilling life and it's sort of your
answer to or your version of these
five-week boat trips that you went on as
a kid right yeah it's your way of
providing that for your boys yeah that
Adventure that unknown risk taking
fear
um I mean I remember distinctly in Nepal
coming into this
Village right at the time when all the
kids were getting out of school you know
and they're all different ages and my
kids eyes are just like oh my gosh I've
never seen anything like this and they
proceeded to spend like four hours
playing tag with 50 kids from this
Village and none of them could
communicate but they're just oh my God
they had the best time ever
and running around and just getting
dirty and you know watching our dinner
which was you know this local goat get
slaughtered and
cut up and put on the table and just um
it was really I mean they talk about it
a lot still just like remember those
kids and how you know it was made a huge
impression on them
and uh
I I guess that is somehow how I
reconcile it it's often it's really hard
for me if you can imagine being on an
expedition like Burma for example where
you are just out there for
weeks and weeks on end and then you come
back to mirrors where you can see
yourself I mean I didn't have a shower
for over a month
and
running water and these these little
things that come back into your world
slowly and you just have
this recognition of them and this
appreciation of it and of course you
know then you're back in the States and
six months later you forget about it but
at the time it's really it takes eye
opening forget about it I mean I
remember first walking into this hotel
and having a huge Buffet of food and
we've been living off of white rice
three meal two meals a day for two weeks
and I couldn't
I couldn't engage I couldn't
I just wanted more white rice I didn't
know how to
engage back into that world it's like
the the homeless person that you provide
a bed and then they end up sleeping on
the floor right and uh yeah there's an
acclimation period that has to take
place yeah that's interesting
um as a mom
you know what what sort of sets you
apart from your fellow climbers beyond
the fact that you've done these
extraordinary things and and your woman
is that you are a mom right and so
that it makes it
um heightened you know when you decide
like okay I'm gonna do this Expedition I
mean I read you did an expedition when
your your boy was 10 months old right
and so that's a very I would imagine a
difficult decision to make
and
I would imagine also plays into how you
assess risk now
now right so how does that work for you
like and it kind of goes back to the
balance question right like yeah like
this is who you are like to repress that
because you're a mom that would be to
kind of contravene your blueprint right
so to speak yet it's undeniable that you
know children need their mother and and
obviously you don't want to go take
undue risk so how does that like
interplay is very complicated it sounds
like to figure that out right I mean
that particular time in my life that
particular Expedition I mean that was a
complete crazy person on that trip to
Pakistan but I was so
so terrified of not
picking up that part of my life and I
think part of that goes back to my own
childhood again and
having an amazing mom who stayed at home
and drove us drove me to all those damn
basketball games all over the place and
um but also had this huge
she didn't have her own identity in the
sense that once we were all gone she you
know she had a really hard time and she
talked about a lot of her regrets you
know I was the youngest child so I
basically spent my whole High School
home you know as the only kid
and it was heartburn that really left an
impression on me of like oh my God I
have to keep my own identity I have to
keep my own identity right to the point
into the family equation right right
like she wasn't able to express herself
yeah and just yeah and just always
talked about all these things she wanted
to do but was never I mean she came from
you know a small family that lived on
Orcas Island with like five kids in her
high school and so in her trajectory of
life she made a lot of changes and did a
lot of crazy Adventures but just
very different and it just stuck with me
that I had to keep this identity I had
to keep myself because I thought that
would be a better way to be a better mom
and to
have my kids see me as a as a person
and and they're probably old enough now
where they can understand what it is
that you do right yeah like so what is
it what do they think what do they say
I mean they think it's great you know
someone asked me the other day if my
kids have ever asked me to stop and stay
home don't just stay home don't go mom
and
no you know they never have like this is
um
the way they
are in our family and in my life it's
it's normal to them what I do
and they love it and they think it's
great you know and I try to like
incorporate it by going to their schools
and talking about things and you know
they've they've been to some of these
National Geographic live shows and they
get I mean they you know they hiked into
makalu base camp with me and uh
instead you know they get out the globe
and they're like we want to go here next
we want to see this or I have a friend
at school that's from Australia and when
can we go there and so they have a
almost the opposite reaction
versus you know no Mom don't go that
it's like when we want to go with you
where are we going to go so but I didn't
know that at the time like I didn't know
how following this path
as a mother and when my kids were young
I didn't know how it was going to turn
out and it was pretty terrifying for me
and I was like what you know what if I'm
doing permanent damage to my kids or
they hate me or you know I mean I think
every parent has that fear yeah every
parent yeah you're totally screwing up
your kids you know yeah and and you know
whatever whatever we're doing we're
making mistake we're all making mistakes
right like nobody's doing this perfectly
but I think just the fact that you have
that impulse means you're conscious of
that that you're aware of that which
probably means that you're a good parent
it's the person who doesn't think about
that kind of thing that yeah I would
worry about but I think what's
interesting about that what you just
said is you know a conservative
traditionalist's perspective would be
look you know you've had your good times
Hillary it's time to like be a mom you
can't do all those crazy things you're
you're prior you got to do whatever but
I think the the alternative perspective
and the perspective that I would share
an offer is that there's something
incred incredibly powerful and
empowering about a parental figure or
anyone for that matter who is so uh
who's whose life is so consistent with
their Dharma like you are you are being
who you are right unapologetically in a
very Fierce and and it's taken me a long
time to get to that for sure
yeah be quiet because I'm going to play
because okay I'm like but but that is a
powerful example for a child to see hey
my mom's a badass like she all these
people are telling her you shouldn't do
this shouldn't do that and she does it
anyway and she kicks ass and and she
she's not gonna apologize for who she is
you know and there's something like so
so life-affirming about that you know
that yeah and and you know even at a
young age like they get that you know
they get that like you've met obstacles
you've overcome them or or even when you
know you don't reach these you don't
reach the Peaks to the whatever you
tried you know you put yourself out
there
and I think as much as anything that is
a message that is important for kids to
see like to say yeah I I have this other
thing I want to do and like if she can
go and do that then like maybe I can go
and do this right right whatever that is
it will be you know different from you
um but I think that you know we'd
probably be better off with more more
people who you know lived boldly in that
regard and of course it comes with its
risks right yeah but what would you do
if
one of your kids was like I just want to
play video games you know I was like you
go Burma no like I'm staying here and
I'm gonna be a video game guy like if it
was just you know it's like that right
it's like I mean
they really love their videos our kids
are our greatest teachers right yeah and
it's like oh my kids are gonna be
they're gonna love the things that I
love and you know inevitably it's not
it's it's wired to not be that way so
that you have that tension right and
there's something to be learned from
that right and I see that even in my own
childhood and growing up and how I like
so with your dad right yeah right you
rebound a different direction and I mean
that is the point of
a parent you live in a child
relationship is like I don't want to ski
I don't I hate the snow I want to live
in Hawaii or whatever I mean
unfortunately fortunately like I I have
plenty of friends in Telluride whose
kids are like that and you know it takes
some
getting used to but you know they
they're interested in other things and
again I just it makes me go back to
hopefully it's not video games but like
I want my kids just to be passionate
about something you know about something
just to have
some
emotional attachment that gives them
a North as you said gives them that is a
compass in their life
gives them something to wake up in the
morning for
and
hopefully because what I know what that
Compass is for me is just Wilderness and
snow you know hopefully I would love it
if that was a part of their life but it
doesn't need to be
all of their life but you know
right well well maybe that's some some
growth uh
like you're not gonna be your dad right
right yeah and they're not going to be
me and they're not going to be their dad
yeah exactly right
well more will be revealed I suppose
right I suppose I mean you have kids too
like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um yeah and it's like you know they they
you think it's going to be one way and
then it's a different way and it's like
how do you flow with that and right how
do you love and support them when they
have interests that are in things that
like you wouldn't be interested in you
know what I mean like that's that's all
part of it and in some ways it's been
really
I mean I think it's one of the most
amazing aspects of being a parent is
having these little
Minds that see things for the first time
and remind me to not be so jaded and to
to see things through their eyes and it
sounds totally cliche but it is and
that's the amazing part about being a
parent is like oh yeah like
it this is an amazing thing like and
notice the little things that affect
their day or make them you know that
it's
to
I have a friend Rob Bell and he says
that you know we all need to live our
lives with a little bit more awe and
wonder right and kids wake up in the
morning with awe and wonder and we and
we lose it yeah and you know living an
adventurous life like you do there's a
lot of awe and wonder yeah right yeah I
think that's as much of what I'm
passionate about is anything
what do you think people
don't
understand about what you do like if if
people have some misapprehension or they
don't really get like what is this ski
mountaineering thing like what is what
is it that you wish they understood that
you understand about it
or just Adventure in general I mean I
think
I would like people to understand that
there there's so much more to it than
the summit at the end of the day
the most I've taken
what this adventuring has given me is
the capacity to
be present I wish I could take that
ability to be present into my day-to-day
life at home but it's just really hard
for me
but on an expedition and when you're in
these intense situations you're really
like focused on
one step in front of the other your
whole world is about shelter water food
survival and it's this
incredibly simplistic and Powerful
experience that we've gotten so far away
from
and really that is what
keeps me going back and keep on keeps me
wanting to have these new adventures and
then of course there's just you know
that that all that path along the way of
you know take one Expedition I did to
the Iowa South Georgia where it's where
Shackleton was finally rescued and
he and on that in order to get from the
boat to the mountains you had to walk
through 300 000 penguins and elephant
seals and half the time we'd never even
get to the mountain because we'd just
stop and sit down and hang out with this
crazy Wildlife scene that would unfold
in front of us and like that's the stuff
I take away from it is having those
experiences
yeah
so when you think back on like Burma
it's probably not
um you know like the the last day before
you retreated it's somewhere along the
trail when the motorcycle wiped out or
you know yeah
it's yeah it's the journey and the
obstacles faced that give it value for
you yeah and and
the thing about Burma is it is it's the
human dynamic as well getting to know
myself you get to know other people
really quickly but I wasn't
like I saw the worst side of myself on
that trip as well and I saw you know
really worse sides of we all
it was so raw and we were so strung out
that we all lost it at one point or
another and the beauty of it was that
if somebody lost it the rest would kind
of come in to rally and pick up the
slack and and as a unit we were able to
all get out of there alive which I had
my doubts along the way and
yeah so I saw a really ugly side of
myself on that trip and to know that I'm
capable of that as well as the good
stuff is
um pretty enlightening in some way yeah
does it make you feel less judgmental of
others or does it like deepen that
reservoir of empathy you know for other
people
um
reservoir of empathy and I've definitely
had a lot of pedestals that I stood on
in my 20s and 30s and pretty much been
knocked off of all of those
uh so humility empathy uh
yeah definitely
um I've learned to
be less judgmental and uh
understand that everyone has their own
history that they're bringing into a
situation
so yeah and uh I mean the Simplicity
really is kind of what you were talking
about earlier like just if we can just
simplify Our Lives you know we we so
over complicate everything
unnecessarily and it's interesting that
you go and you're so in touch with that
when you're on these Expeditions and
that even you who's gone out and done
things you know the vast majority of
people will never ever do it wears off
when you come back it does it wears off
it's like yeah why can't it stick why
can't I can't stick yeah I mean I'm just
as dick as addicted to my Instagram feed
or whatever as the next person but yet
it seems like what I love about being in
the mountains is like the phone is
nothing's ringing nothing's like in
India they won't let you bring the cell
phone they won't let you bring the
sapphones that's still the law there
that's so crazy they're working on
changing it but I did I got a nice like
stuck it in right I snuck it in in 2013
fortunately because one of our team
members got pulmonary edema so we had to
call in a rescue but you had to call
like somebody in Italy right you
couldn't call anyone in India because
you would get arrested for having the
phone well I got arrested for having the
phone anyways yeah but they wouldn't
answer the phone because they can
recognize a SAT number so we had to call
through Italy and then Italy called
what's the deal with that like why won't
they you know because especially the
region we're in is very close
to there's a lot of drug smuggling and
they're just afraid of you know
terrorism and all that but uh there's
they're working on it there's definitely
ways to figure out how you can yeah
to an expedition or something like that
like they could register them yeah they
register them or you rent them they have
the an international amount or an Indian
mountaineering Federation there so you
know give phones to that Federation and
then you rent them from the
mountaineering Federation they're
they're working on it it would be an
easy fix but there's a lot of uh red
tape in India but back to that that
earlier point you know it's so beautiful
how you describe like being in these
communities and seeing the kids and
they're happy and they're living in you
know like they have nothing yeah and and
there's joy right and so we
intellectualize that and we understand
like oh those people are happy and then
you you go to you know Bakersfield and
you're like yeah people don't look as
happy or whatever it is doesn't matter
but
we're not like going well I'm gonna sell
everything and like move and go live
right
incredibly like romanticizing it too I
mean these kids have incredibly hard
it's hard lies and they don't have long
life expectancies and you know they have
they don't have health care and I mean
it's a heart it's it's a hard life and
I think
oh we're not gonna go backwards as a
society to that
degree and hopefully you know the goal
of humanity is to uplift everyone out of
that poverty
but
we have to can we find Value in
different things I think
yeah can we can we capture
some aspect of of you know where that
Joy is coming from and bring that into
our own lives and and we're not so good
at that no you know no we do like
complicating things we have to uh oh an
hour and a half we got a few more
minutes here
um
so you're speaking tonight speaking
tonight yes about Burma I know so I'm
sort of like wishing that I could have
seen you talk before yeah a little bit
more color into this
um when you get up and and you deliver
these presentations like you're telling
the stories
but what is it that
you want people to walk away with like
what is the message that you're trying
to deliver
uh
I want people to
I mean Be Inspired on one level but also
to embrace
risk-taking
and failure which sounds like two kind
of depressing things but like Embrace
these things because I think it opens up
your
this little box that we live in and
it opens up
your ability to get to know yourself and
your true potential
through taking risks and through failing
and I mean basically that's what this
whole Expedition this Burma talk is
about is
we took a huge risk and we failed on
many levels but you know we also
succeeded because we're all still here
and
yeah what is your metric for success and
failure and right you know I I still I
struggle with this word failure it's
like there's the attempt to you know
live and do something outside of your
comfort zone right and that should be
celebrated no matter what the outcome
because you know upon your return you're
fortified with whatever you learned you
know that you have the experience and
then there's you know whatever that
experience delivered to you in terms of
how you can you know live more fulfill
live better right give more of yourself
to others yeah
so what we get hung up on this word
failure is like oh well you guys didn't
make it to the summit you failed right
right and not one single person has ever
said that to me no not no they're all
like what are you talking about that
wasn't a failure that was amazing you
know or like what an adventure don't
look at it as a failure do you or do you
I mean I did for a while afterwards not
so much because of reaching not reaching
the summit but just because of how our
Team Dynamics just imploded
um on that Ridge and I felt you know as
you know I was supposed to be the glue
for this team and I think I just learned
a lot about how not to lead how to lead
how just the intricacies and you know
sort of
difficulties and in the end though I I
always go back to like God damn it we
signed up for an adventure and that's
what we had so what is all this about
like that's what we got we got what we
wanted
um
you know like buck up and like deal
um
you hear often or I've I've heard often
uh you know this refrain that there are
no great female
um Role Models it's like we're in the
Kardashian culture and as a father of
two young girls I take issue with that
there are amazing
women role models all over the place but
we just don't do a very good job of
celebrating them or making sure that
they're in the spotlight because there's
people like yourself that are
you know doing amazing things everywhere
so how do you think about like your role
as
as uh you know as a as a woman as a
female role model to you know young
girls as somebody you know that they can
look up to do you spend time thinking
about that or you're just doing what
you're doing I do more and more uh I
mean if you look up like female
explorers on the Great Wide Web yeah are
you the first Google person no you get
Dora the Explorer you know it's like
come on like so I think it's
um
so more and more I I really do think
about
what it means to be a role model for
young girls and
there are so many Role Models out there
and really it's just a matter of
um you know I I think in a lot of ways
women are
suit you can correct me if you don't
agree but somewhat Superior storytellers
especially in terms of Adventure because
we talk about it so differently than the
keepers of the male story
um and I agree with that yeah it's
especially when it comes to like
Adventure and climbing and and
in that genre we've I feel like women
speak about it very differently than men
and and have an incredibly different
unique perspective what's to be told
well
I mean just in us talking right now and
granted you're asking the questions but
we're not talking about
the peak of evil and climbing and
standing on top and how many Summits
I've made and this that now that we're
talking about I don't care about that
kids I know but we're you know it's just
like you're talking about these stories
of
of just more just emotional what does it
mean what it what is the point
and I think you're seeing the sprouting
up of a lot of female Adventure writers
as well as adventurous and
uh
I think that through speaking for me I
can affect
girls and their idea of what it means to
be
a woman in the workplace a woman in
adventure a role model uh what what it
means to you know occupy a space that is
typically male dominated and how how to
how to
still
take on that space But be a woman and be
a female and understand that there's
huge value in that because of the
different perspective you have and uh
yeah I guess did that answer your
question no it's good it's powerful no I
mean that's that's the heart of it right
that's the heart of it and it you know
it's we're talking about the Perils of
the modern world and you know like I
said I have two daughters like I see the
influences and as much as you try to
guide and and and you know kind of like
insulate them from some of that it's
it's impossible right it's there it is
you know it is omnipresence right
culture and you have to work to kind of
get outside of that right and I think
like you can do that with like even the
companies I work with that North Face
for example you know they need to be
able to
represent their female athletes in the
same way and with the same push as the
males and they're working really hard at
doing that and I think that's how you
get
female role models
out there so that when you hit Explorer
you don't get Dora you get
Lynn Hill and you get Angel Collinson
and Margo and you know Ashima and all
you know all of these incredible women
out there doing incredible things and I
pay attention more than most people and
I don't know who those people are right
and I feel and I feel guilty like I
should right right yeah so they're just
climbers I know it's cool
it's cool well
um we gotta wrap this up but that was
awesome how do you feel did we do it
yeah what did we not talk about is there
more stuff my head's spinning
very inspiring thank you thank you thank
you for coming but also but more than
that like thank you for what you do
thank you for you know being this
example and uh and I just want more
people to hear your voice and yeah
things continue doing what you're doing
do you have a sense of what your next
adventure may be or is that percolating
yeah no I
um
I'm going to spend and a few weeks with
Jim Morrison my partner in life and all
things and do some climbing in the
Sierras sort of as a training platform
for going back up to the Arctic National
Wildlife Refuge it's one of like my
favorite places on this entire planet
I've never been anywhere like it and as
you know there's a lot of
political and environmental stuff going
on up there so I'm going to spend a
couple weeks up there with another
athlete kit delorey I
um at the end of April and
explore and sort of document what a
beautiful unique place it is in hopes of
influencing
some policy or something we could use
some of that yeah that's that's the next
podcast yeah get into that yeah um well
that's very cool and you're kind of on
this this speaking tour yeah of sorts at
the moment I mean the theater you're
speaking out it's a Thousand Oaks civil
Civic Civic Art Center yeah it's a
beautiful theater yeah um it's been the
coolest part of touring is I mean that's
a big theater yeah yeah so how many do
you have more cities coming up like
where
um I'm kind of done for the season I
just have one more at the Mesa Arts
Center I think in
um Mesa Arizona Phoenix yeah cool
um I've been in that theater too that's
nice
really good theaters the Seattle theater
the minor Royal was in there that was a
really good theater
um one in Kansas City it was incredible
there's some good ones Pro theater in
Dallas
right yeah they have this National
Geographic live Series so
um different cities hosts anywhere from
three to five shows in a season and you
can you buy like seasons passes for it
it's pretty cool it's cool they usually
do it in the winter you know when it's
dark and cold and yeah people can go
listen to good stories awesome yeah well
good luck tonight thank you and good
luck to you in life in general yeah
thanks to you all right so people uh
want to want to connect with Hillary
first of all final question
is it still Hillary O'Neil or is it
Hillary Nelson now like Hillary Nelson
Laurie Nelson yeah okay good I'm glad I
asked you that yeah yeah but it's it's
still transitioning yeah you're like
Hillary O'Neal on Twitter and yeah I
could tell like your website's Hillary
Nelson yeah some kind of Hillary Nelson
O'Neill but it's transitioning to
Hillary now I got you yeah cool
um my maiden name from my right I'm
divorced so yeah all right well cool
um after your next Expedition come back
and talk to me about it some more maybe
all right all right cool good thanks
thank you thanks for having me thank you
[Music]